At the World Economic Forum on Africa
in Dar es Salaam, Tanzania,
we are setting up a
Davos Debates video corner.
Here, participants including
presidents and business leaders
will respond via video to your questions and ideas
on the region's most pressing challenges.
So, what is your vision for Africa? And what
opportunities and barriers does Africa face?
What questions do you have for the
leaders who will gather in Dar es Salaam?
Send your ideas and questions via
video or text to YouTube.com/Davos.
You can also vote on your favourite contributions from others.
The contributions with the highest number of votes
will be put to the leaders at
the Davos Debates corner
giving you direct access to some of the most
powerful and influential people in the world.
The best entries may also
be shown at the meeting.
Tell us what you think.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos
to join the conversation.